today I'm going to talk about following
your flow so one of the most important
lessons that I've learned in business
and I guess in life is you need to
follow your flow and sometimes there are
external pressures that force you into
following your flow you may get a big
media opportunity you may get a new
partnership you may get a new a big
customer that kind of is a huge big
opportunity for your business and
sometimes following your flow i find
comes from internal reasons internal
pressures maybe you wake up one day and
you really want to go try something out
or you're on a walk or you in a shower
and a new thing comes to your mind and
and i found that by following my flow
and by following that idea it's always
in my best interest one because probably
magic is going to happen if magic is
going to happen it's going to come from
a source of inspiration not just being
you know doing your day to day to day to
day and to I didn't want to live with
regret you know don't want to have this
big list of to do is this big list of
ideas that just builds and builds and
builds and this Evernote file that just
keeps growing I never actually take
action on stuff right you have an idea
you want to try something go and take
action on it so yesterday does this
relates to my book yesterday I had a
full day plan monday is my busy day I'm
record this on Tuesdays Monday it's are
my my busiest day of the week and I had
a full day plant in it and then I just
it all exploded on me from an external
source from 50 cent so i made a video
and 50 cent saw it and he called it good
and he posted on his Facebook page and
he posted it to his Twitter account he
posted a blog about it he kind of went
crazy promoting this and and as a result
the traffic exploded on my video
comments were coming out of everywhere
people were tweeting me their summit for
my newsletter they're engaging with the
video it was just insane and I had a
choice of hey I can either go with this
right or I could just do all the work
that I had plan for the day and I chose
to go with it on top of it was pretty
cool right 50 cent likes my stuff and is
sharing it and I spent a good amount of
time just with my team
just having fun in the moment looking at
the number seeing where it was being
shared it's kind of a big celebration
and a win for everybody on the team so
we're all kind of super pumped and
excited and I spent the day responding
to everybody and as a result got nothing
done that I was supposed to get done for
the day and so that bled into what I'm
doing today and I as a result today I
didn't get a lot of stuff done on terms
of writing the book there's one thing I
have to do with Jen my right ear asked
me to look at some of the stuff she
wrote and so I'm going to check it i
would give her some feedback but i
thought it'd be a good decision and as
always i typically have a pretty
scheduled day but i'm not afraid to
abandon everything to follow my flow and
i encourage you guys who do think
because i think it'll really help you in
your business and in your life I hope
the audio is coming out okay because
it's raining i seem to always film these
in the ring so now to your questions I
love entering your comments let's start
it off Michael Sofia wait you're writing
the book can't wait yes bro right in the
book looking forward to it next stike 96
how do you manage to stay on past the
whole day while you're writing I know
you don't check emails or anything at
that time and you try to keep away from
distractions but things can just pop
like the doorbell rings or you remember
that you need to get something from the
store for dinner or something how would
you be able to go the whole day without
getting distracted by stuff like that
because I imagine if you want and did
those things you would probably forget
what you're writing and and have to look
back over everything again I certainly
would yeah that's a huge not just for
writing any any major project you know
answering an email is a short thing
usually but any time you're doing
something creative whether it's writing
an article whether it's right in the
book whether it's designing a new
website whether it's painting a piece of
art or composing a song you get into
creative flow and that takes time to get
into and when you get distracted it
takes insane amounts of time to get back
to it so what I do is I try to create a
no distraction life as much as possible
I don't have a phone I don't have a cell
phone i use skype for external calls so
nobody can call me i don't have people
really ringing my doorbell people say
why don't you have a phone i said well
because when you have a phone people
call you and they're kind of shocked by
that answer but i don't want people
calling me a cell phone i find it
other people's agenda for your time
anyway i know i'm weird in that respect
but it allows me to focus way more on
what i'm doing during the day I don't
check my emails I have a the way I do it
is every morning I check my emails from
a certain folder of a folder where all
the important important people in my
life go friends family important
suppliers important clients media going
to one folder and I answer that in the
morning and that doesn't take too long
and then everybody else goes to general
folder and I answer that when I have
time in between breaks whatever but I'm
definitely not checking that when I'm
when I'm writing same thing for social
media right I'll check that in the
morning and then I don't i'm not in like
I'm not checking Facebook and Twitter
and all the other stuff during the day
I'm focusing on my task and so I find
that really helps I guess the other
thing is chunk in the day where I know
usually tuesdays my writing day and I
block off that day and I plan around
this I don't book meetings on that day I
don't take calls on that day don't try
to do admin stuff on that day don't try
to do anything unless again it's
something super important and I'm
following my flow on otherwise I tend to
stick to a usual schedule on that make
sure that I can get this stuff out on
time Chris 7820 that's great Evan I do
find myself sleeping and rereading pages
in a book yeah that's something that
bothers me so much in a book and
something I really don't want to have is
I'm reading the book and I have to read
it over again and read it over again a
while I'm reading it I'm thinking of
something else and so then I have to
read the page again like I think a book
should be captivating like captivate me
so much and this is not just for a book
it's your website copy it's your YouTube
video it's your tweet so everything
everything you're putting out captivate
me so I'm not thinking of something else
while I'm reading your stuff right and I
think a lot of books don't do that and I
don't want to have that boring book that
you read three pages up and then totally
didn't remember what anything setting up
to reread it again so thank you for that
comment and I'm keeping that top of mind
as I right bro next Tamara weeks I'm
loving these book videos what a journey
and thank you for including me Thank You
Tamara great question thank you for your
loyalty to the channel always appreciate
it next up is home and well done Evan
this is a great way of letting us know
your process
of doing a book and also great way to
stir interest I'm in question I watch a
video from the 21 convention the other
day with a topped presented by lad
called Matthew Hussey excellent info he
said when we find people who we felt a
connection with and we're looking to as
role models awesome or find out what are
their ritual so what are your rituals
dude hope that makes sense cool um I
don't know how much that relates to the
book but rituals I got a lot of rituals
that's a subject for many many many many
many many videos I think the one that's
may be most helpful to me and most
relevant that I'll share is my morning
ritual I find that my the way I used to
live was you know I get up and just do
whatever work that I have is hot on my
plate and then I find that maybe at like
three o'clock or four o'clock wherever I
might watch a video or might get
inspired by something might have a
conversation with somebody and then I
get inspired and then I'd be like super
hungry like yeah I want to go do that or
maybe that happened at night or maybe in
some things it didn't happen at all uh
and then I thought why am i leaving that
to chance like why am i leading into a
chance video that i watch or a chance
meeting i have with somebody why don't I
schedule that in right and in the
morning I start off and I've talked
about a couple times but the morning my
usual routine is I have a quick session
of gratitude where write down things
through things that I'm grateful for
during the day and I send my wife a
message cuz she's use the other door
even before I wake up so just send her a
quick message saying I love you
something like that starting the day
with gratitude and love then I'll put on
some music I think music immediately
changes your state I have a belief
playlist that that I love and listen to
and you just want music that hmm you
know makes you do that makes it Bob
makes you dance what I like is going to
be different than what you like and
that's totally cool I'm not saying this
one perfect song although we did come up
with with the don't song that's uh I
like it's kind of an entrepreneur anthem
but put on music that makes you [ __ ] a
lot because in the morning you can be
sluggish and slow or maybe you didn't
sleep that well so getting music on that
makes you move I find immediately gets
you a little more excited I'll do a
quick workout and then
I'll look at my youtube comments and my
videos and i created the nth special
series as a way to it was a selfish
reason it was a way for me to say
motivated in the morning right i wanted
something every morning that would
inspire me to think bigger like yes I'm
super proud of what I have I'm really
grateful for everything that that i
built and for you guys for watching I
love my life right now but I want to
have a bigger impact right I want to be
driven to want to do more and reach more
people and having a big goal helps but I
find having a morning routine where
instead of by chains coming across a
video that excites you I put that into
my morning schedule and I created it to
that it can inspire me and hopefully
inspire you guys to and I find that that
combination of starting with gratitude
in love and then putting on music to
change my state and then watching the
ants wrestle series and and trying to
surround myself with greatness sets me
up really well for the day to want to go
and do something big and important and
maybe doesn't work every single day I'd
be lying that every single day I wake up
super excited super motivate ready to
take on the world yeah for most days and
so that works me I'm constantly tweaking
it but I'm curious to learn what works
for you actually what do you guys do
what's your ritual below i'm curious
next ex naruto one outsourced automated
cetera for work week it's really
interesting to see the various books you
recommend in your seven books every
entrepreneur should read through the
videos i remember even one video you
shared a story of someone who went
through gold-mining to sell insurance
which came from the ticking Bell rich
book I believe that I might have gotten
the title wrong I don't know I find it
interesting to see all your verse
influences you talk about and come
across room videos in various ways yeah
i'm not sure that example is on but you
know i made that video the seven books
because those books had a huge impact on
me and i hope that it can inspire other
people as well and people asking a lot
what books do your books you read
instead of responding every time I felt
hey I'll make a video on it um yeah you
know I try to include the things that I
I'm influence behind the books that I
read and the places I go and my views in
every video you know I'm me um that
sit you know the easiest way the easiest
way to live I find is not to not to try
to be somebody else and not try to lie
and then keep track of what lies you
told this rain is insane and so I
reference those books because I've read
those books because those books have
meaning to me right so I'm glad that
that comes out and I think for anybody
who's trying to build an audience being
authentic is super important and super
relevant and not everybody's going to
drive with you but the people who do
will will love you for next Jackie f 54
suggests outsourcing use ghost riders
then edit it with your thoughts I can't
do that Jackie I can't do that I can't
just outsource the the content because
it's important right I think I think for
anybody writing a book you got to put
you into it right nobody can speak for
me I find and I'm yes it takes longer
and yes is frustrating but I'm going to
be super proud of it and I can't just
give it to somebody else and say hey you
write this for me because my words are
important and I put a lot of value into
it and the stuff that I create from my
audience suffering it's like have
somebody come on here and and do this
video for me right and answer these
questions for me nobody can answer them
like me not that I'm the greatest just
nobody can see them like me right you're
asking me a question I'm giving you an
answer and that's what I feel is with
the book too I don't want to be just
some cover where I put my name on it but
it's not actually me behind it and I've
done some editing on it right to me
that's not cool I'd rather not write a
book and so yes even though it's
frustrating and painful um I'm doing it
myself and it you know I'm getting some
help where it's not my words being
spoken and I mentioned that in last
week's video but yeah I don't want to
just outsource an edited next up Luthor
man Evan your video making machine
nearly 1,900 videos Wow Luther bro
follow your passion follow your flow you
like something you find something that
you enjoy you go all-in man this week I
just brought on three new people to help
me with my youtube channel I'm the front
man but I need help having it behind the
scenes I have brought on a cameraman
recently I brought on a researcher I
brought an ex
editor I brought on somebody help with
my comments um yeah when you love
something you go all-in you own it man
okay 1900 videos is nothing more is
coming I'm proud of it I'm happy with it
I'm passionate about it hopefully you
can feel that here and I hope that you
find something that you're so excited
about that you want to go all in on and
it doesn't seem like a lot of work
there's 1,900 videos to me doesn't seem
like tons next up sino or chino thanks
to the video ever and led to this topic
two videos per day feels like a whole
lot to me i truly appreciate the value
on your inside and energy put out as a
viewer as much as i can i oh I got cut
off I think it would I think the common
stuff like I have a hard time keeping up
I'm making another video about this i'm
not sure about the timing maybe maybe
you will have already be released by the
time this one comes out but i've never
seen myself as a show right i have a
channel not a show and that's the
difference in size right I don't care if
everybody watches every single episode
on my channel but I'm putting up
different shows right so this book
series is one show the ents presso is a
show the top 10 is a show the ass kevin
is a show these are all different shows
on my channel and I matching at me
adding more content and it's okay if you
can't keep up with everything you know
when you turn on ESPN NBC you're not
watching every single show that they
have on there but there's something
about that channel that you really like
and so that's how I see myself I'm not
limiting myself as saying hey I'm only
going to do one show per week or one
show per day and i truly appreciate am
and grateful for everybody who's
watching these different videos and your
comments and i don't expect everybody to
keep up with every single video that's
okay that's cool like take the stuff
that you are interested in that works
for you you can apply to your business
at the end of the day I want to see your
business take off and grow and so as
much as I can help with that you know
that's not going to happen by you just
sitting and watching me 24 hours a day
right you got to get to work you got to
do some work and so take what you like
from my channel take whatever shows you
want to consume I always appreciate the
views and alikes in the comments and
shares and if it doesn't work
for you you know if one is not as
inspiring us as another that's cool too
you know don't watch it but if we shoot
the feedback that's it I'm going to wrap
up hopefully you guys could hear the
rain is getting out of control and kind
of dripping down my back love you guys
thank you for your support on my journey
as a writer I book if you have questions
for me about my book process or writing
a book in general or anything related to
the book leave it below comment down and
I'll answer it in extras video thank you
guys believe